hello and welcome today we're going to
look at in ordinary differential
equations by Ricky Chen Yu Lee aruba
Nova Jesse Betancourt and David Devon oh
so there's been quite an interesting
kind of paper to see because it's a bit
special we're going to go over parts of
it not the full paper just kind of the
important parts because the paper is
quite packed and we'd rather I'd rather
explain it in parts and kind of get the
gist of it so basically what they do is
they they say introduce a new family of
deep neural network models instead of
specifying a discrete sequence of hit
layers we patterned parametrize the
derivative of the hidden state using a
neural network the output of the network
is computed using a black box
differential equation solver this
contained these continues depth models
have constant memory cost adapt their
evaluation strategy to each input can
explicitly trade the amiracle precision
for speed I mean this it sounds awesome
honestly it sounds really cool and it
sounds really new and yeah all right
let's jump in so what they say is let's
look at kind of classic neural networks
especially residual neural networks
so what residual neural networks do is
in each hidden layer they kind of have a
representation HT it's this kind of
their hidden representation at layer T
and what they do is they then add
something so if you don't know a
recurrent neural network is where you
have let's say this is your hidden state
HT and in a classic neural network you
would just have a weight matrix here
claw blah blah blah you do a matrix
multiplication to get HT plus 1 so to
get the next kind of the next hidden
state you do a matrix multiplication by
big weight matrix here W right in a
residual neural network what you do is
you have this weight matrix W you
multiply it to get
delta h t plus one and you take HT and
you add the two right do you add h t and
delta h t plus one to arrive at HT plus
one so that's a residual network it
basically doesn't learn the
transformation to the next layer but it
learns what how is the next
representation different from this
representation right so what do i need
to add to this representation to get to
the next representation which is it's
kind of its reason that for deep
networks since each layer only does a
little bit of transformation we should
basically bias it towards keeping the
representation the same and just kind of
changing it a little bit so that's the
inherent bias is the identity transform
right so that's an order that's a
residual little residual network
this here is characterized by F of kind
of theta and an HT so this is kind of
the this is what we called Delta H it's
not it's not called F so this F would be
the kind of neural network layer and
theta would be the parameters of it so
the weight matrix in our case they say
okay what if you do many of those right
so they say basically what this is is
kind of a time process right it's kind
of you have a state and the next state
in the next step you always learn how to
go to the next state to the next state
and so on if what if you go very deep
and what if you look at this as a time
process and kind of make these steps
very small right make this super small
and basically what if you have many many
infinitely many layers I say well okay
this then becomes a dynamic process
basically an ordinary differential
equation where I say okay my time is now
continuous and I look at it as a
linearization
as a local linearization basically and I
say okay I basically specify how to get
from this time to the next instance of
time the next instant the next
infinitesimally small instance of time
by specifying this F and in the
continuous case this this is to say that
the derivative of the hidden state is
now parameterised by a neural network
right so if you know what a differential
equation is it has like here's like like
this locator here it's like a start
state and then what you do is you
specify how in each at each point in
time so that's T at each point in time
how does the gradient look so maybe the
gradient looks like this and then what
the no te solver will do is the OD es
Oliver will say okay the gradient I'm
gonna do an infinite small step in this
direction and then it goes back to F a F
what's the gradient at this infinitely
small step next in time and then F would
say well that the gradient is is like
this and then the Odie's are like okay I
need to be a little bit flatter so I go
here so what's the gradient at this time
okay maybe it's up there so I need to go
up here so the OTE solver will kind of
construct the curve and at each point it
needs to look that whatever F says is
the gradient is actually the gradient
right if this is the gradient this is
the gradient this is the gradient so
that's that's kind of how an OD e works
and that's they say okay you can
actually look at residual networks here
as being a discrete-time analogue to
such an OD so what we want to do is
actually we want to specify every one
actually and this is the the crazy part
right or the cool part
is we wanna do this for our neural
networks basically we simply specify an
OD and the start state here the start
state is let's say if you want to build
an EM missed class where it's our it's
our image right the start state is our
amnesty edge and we're simply training a
neural network such that the OD the
equation if you solve it the curve at
the end will arrive at the correct class
I mean that's that's I'm skipping a few
parts here about dimensionalities and so
on right because you need to keep in the
same dimension but in essence they say
here we start out with our input and we
train the neural network to give us the
correct gradients they've to correct
derivatives of this curve at each point
in time such that when you solve though
de at the end point you are going to be
at the correct label so that's this is
the input trainer to your task
basically and this is the output right
but instead of having a neural network
go from input to output you have a
neural network that parameter eise's how
you go from each step in time to the
next one what's what's the gradient at
each point in time that's that's the the
kind of gist of it and that's that's
kind of really cool it's a really new
approach all right so they do give
various advantages of this and so here
is this demonstrated again right you are
here this is your input and you wanna go
to the output and then the loss of the
loss that you specify it can depend on
kind of either on the output as in like
an image class for aura can depend on
intermediate states this is it's kept
general right so the way they go out it
is they say well okay but so the neural
network now specifies how to get from
one step to the next right here
and the neural network has parameters
right so we we need to train this neural
network such that the correct output is
given to some input right we actually
need to train it so we need to we need
to some how to train these parameters
theta and they say okay we do gradient
descent on theta like in a classic
neural network but now we need it's not
it's not so easy right
it's not one pass through this function
it's like infinitely many passes through
this function until you arrive here and
then if you you basically need to
somehow get a gradient with respect to
these parameters here so they say this
again the loss of the this is the loss
of the end state right is the loss of
the start state plus the the integral
over time of this is derivative which is
basically this curve and the the curve
is given by an OD is Oliver where we
input all these things so we need
gradients with respect to that how do we
do that and they give away here of
saying okay we could either I kind of
back propagate through the Eau de sauver
but that would you know depend on though
the solver and so on but there's another
method there's called what's called T I
mean we need D what's called the adjoint
so this is a reversible differentiation
of an OD solution the adjoint
sensitivity method solves an Augmented
OD backwards in time so basically what
you need to do is you forward propagate
you come here right and then what you
can do is you can solve a second OD so
you can generate a second curve here
this one and don't worry about these
little jumps here you can solve the
second curve and the second curve
together with the first and the second
curve you can then compute the gradients
you need right so the second curve is is
basically simply something like the
application of the chain rule to the
continuous domain
and you need to you need to adjust these
jumps here only when your loss depends
on intermediate states this is this is
kind of the the offset caused by
including or not including the loss so
let's dive a bit further into this
adjoin state what's the red curve the
red curve is called a and what's a a is
a curve and this is the differential
equation for it again we specify the
curve a by specifying its start state
and its derivative and from its start
state and its derivative at each time
the OTE solver is able to construct the
curve entirely so 80 it says here is del
L 2 del Z T this means how does the loss
depend on this ZT on the hidden state
right how does the loss depend on the
hidden state at time T so it doesn't
even have to be any of these points here
how does the loss depend on this hidden
state here and in order to find that out
you would need to go you will need to
develop the the curve until here right
and then calculate the loss and then
back propagate through here but you can
do this by calculating this adjoint
thing so as you can see here is a
demonstration it's an example right so
the start state here is simply given by
the loss how does the loss of this state
how does the loss depend on this state
well simply by plugging it into D into
the loss equation right so your loss is
my cross entropy loss or something how
does the loss depend on this state here
well we go we go from this state that we
already know and we know how in reverse
time so backwards in time this
sensitivity of the loss develops so we
go and we develop this curve until here
we say aha
this point influences this loss in this
much basically right so so and if the
loss explicitly depends on this point
then we have to we have to calculate in
this offset since this point here only
depends on this time up till here
and then it changes so there is Thursday
at this continuation but yeah don't
worry about that too much basically what
we can do is we can calculate the curve
in a forward pass the curve and the loss
in the forward pass then we can do a
second pass backward again by an OD
solve to say how does the how does the
loss depend on each one of the states
here of the hidden States right so
that's the second point but that's not
all because we're altom utley not
interested in the how the lost depends
on hidden state where the we're
interested in how the loss depends on
these parameters that tell us how to get
from one hidden state to the next but
luckily we can then simply evaluate this
integral that depends as you can see
here on a and on Z we can evaluate this
and get the gradients for the the
parameters right so I also have to say
the parameters are static so the
parameters are given over the entire
duration of this there they're the same
simply what changes is time all right so
this is how you can get this is how you
can get gradients with respect to
parameters and the cool thing is now you
can train these you can actually train
this neural network here that tells you
how to go from
state to the next such that if you input
the digit to as an image you can output
to I mean not exactly but that's that's
the point right you can by by going
through this motion by going through
this OD solve so that's I mean that's
immensely cool they actually define how
to do this here in one forward one kind
of backward pass you can solve
everything at the same time it's pretty
cool and they evaluate their their net
and and they compare it with a bunch of
other nets and they interestingly show
that so basically with a no de solver
you can never kind of tell how many
evaluations it's going to do because
it's going to get increasing like it's
increasingly accurate over time so you
let it run and maybe it's going to first
generate a curve that's like something
like this right and then it needs to say
crap okay I need to to go back and
refine and then it maybe goes that curve
like this and so on so it gets
continually closer over time and for
that it needs to kind of query it's like
a query it needs to query this this F so
you need to give it the function as an e
value above function and it goes ask
okay I need to I need to know it here
okay I got it from here okay I need to
know it here okay I got it from me oh no
I didn't get it okay and it also need to
know it here
all right now and so you can never know
how much they will evaluate but you
basically have a parameter to trade off
accuracy and how much they value eight
that's what they show here so the the
less error they want in their forward
pass the more forward passes they have
to do that's this curve the more forward
passes they do the more time they have
to invest right that's this curve well
interestingly the more forward passes
the time required for forward passes or
the evaluations required for passes
increases also the evaluation required
for backward passes but not by much so
the
that the backrub has require about half
the amount of evaluations as forward
passes which is encouraging since the
the backward passes don't go kind of
overboard like if you had to back
propagate through the operations of the
audience all over itself and they also
show as your training epoch continues
that the the OD solver requests more and
more evaluations for some for the same
epoch basically or the same samples
within different epochs which means as
it gets more accurate kind of it needs
to know more and more and more about the
samples basically about the tests at the
training samples which is all basically
showing that this kind of works yeah so
they they kind of get into normalizing
flows which I don't want to get into
here much because we haven't done a
video on that yeah well do one but they
basically show that it's it's quite easy
to do
normalizing flows in a continuous
fashion and at the top of normalizing
flows it's in itself pretty cool what
they do at the end is they say okay what
we can now do is we can actually take
sequential data so now we've just talked
about let's input one data point and get
out let's say a label or something which
we can actually do sequential data and
let's for example have an order an
encoder for our sequential data so here
here these are data points right these
are measurements like a blood pressure
of a of a person and what we can do is
we can do a variational auto encoder
we've talked about this we can have an
Oran n encoder parametrize a
distribution and then as a decoder have
this OTE neural network and basically
what that allows us to do is that is to
deal with time steps that are not
regularly sampled and so we can
extrapolate from the data point at at
time yeah times not
regular samplings like or with Oran ends
you basically forced to have always the
same time step difference otherwise you
have a very tough time but with this
since these are continuous flows your
race you can basically unroll them and
evaluate them at whatever time you want
so they have pretty cool experiments
here where they kind of try to learn
these kind of spiraling behaviors and
you see on top the RNN decoder will get
all
Jaggi and so on where as the so so
basically as the the neural ordinary
differential equation will generate
quite let's say smooth things and also
it can extrapolate as you can see here
you can it can go the red the red thing
is the extrapolation only there's only
data where the green dots are so that's
pretty cool you can see the RNN
sometimes isn't able to kind of continue
the flow as you can see in here it
extrapolates wrongly so the this kind of
i mean it's a toy it's a toy example but
these kind of dynamics are pretty cool
and they also show here when they learn
the spirals and very one dimension of
the latent code that is given by the
encoder then the flow goes from
clockwise it goes from two to
counterclockwise as you see here I've
turned this I drawn this ain't wrong but
so it's pretty pretty cool what these
these things learn and since it's only
small data right now small models but
I'm pretty sure this is going to develop
further and be a cool just a cool way
cool ally of research cool idea and
looking forward to what they come up
next all right so that was it for today
a bit shorter but I hope
this was somewhat clear enough all right
have a great day